howdy howdy howdy welcome back to M
cubed and sidetrack
combined together again
but for greatness uh Niraj is already
here that's that's our editor slash uh
graphic guy hell yeah welcome welcome uh
uh welcome anybody else that pops in and
stuff it's it's Cinema scoop Wednesday
y'all know the deal we're talking movie
news in the middle of the week they they
don't always know the deal because we're
all so on sidetracking that's true we're
having a little bit of an experiment
we're running the stream on both
channels
confusing
but we want to we want to spread the
love towards you Harris so one way we
can do that is get on sidetrack
and ask people very nicely if they
wouldn't mind going to subscribe to M3
or M cubed or whatever you call it or
whatever you're feeling it all works as
long as there's in there yes yes we
don't even know if it's working no but
but hey we got eight people in here
welcome everybody Welcome to anybody
else hopping in later uh we do have some
fun things to talk about not not like a
whole whole slew of things like we
usually do sometimes we'll have seven
eight nine kind of things to go over I
think we got a solid
three four five and then uh got a couple
reviews I guess for Mission Impossible
seven so uh yeah you ready to dive in
let's do it all right
uh Bob says I like most things TC does
but as Tom Cruise does but his mission
impossible reboot has always left me
cold really really well it doesn't leave
most people cold it definitely doesn't
leave Tom Cruise cold because you know
what he said
he said ching and he said I want to do
these all the way until I'm Harrison
Ford's age and what Harrison Ford is
8283 and Tom Cruise is 61. so that's
two decades more can can you do two
decades more of Mission Impossible
because that has anybody ever had a
career quite like Tom Cruise
Sean Connery
it's like the only other person as long
as as Tom Cruise is I mean Tom Cruise
has been because he was a kid You could
argue the last 10 years has not been
amazing but really he's been at the top
of his game for like what 40 years oh
the last 10 years he's gotten Mission
Impossible five six and Maverick I think
the last 10 years has been great for him
just want to just do a side track
business quickly because we're on both
um
the shuttle pod podcast
[Music]
um
followed me on Twitter after that video
so I was a bit worried they might be
angry at me for nicking edits from their
video but it's such a good such a good
Channel I think it deserves all the love
so as they've yeah I'm assuming they're
not too angry
at me
um but I've dropped him a message just
going love you guys
um and uh yeah we're Trulia and uh yeah
really cool anyway but yeah um I'm I'm
not sure there's ever been an actor or
actress that's been has
consistently
successful
that's Tom Cruise
he's had a few bumps in the road don't
get me wrong but he always comes
straight back I mean you're thinking
even about some of like the greats from
back in the day has anybody had quite
the Korean like guys again the comments
to tell us if you're gonna give anybody
that can actually compete with him the
the two names that come to mind are like
Jody Foster but then again she doesn't
have like those box office bust and
things like that she just had a long
career but she was unknown for like what
20 years of that career did nothing for
years
or Keanu Reeves kind of count there
because he kind of he he wavers and
comes back big and kind of wavers and
comes back big and kind of does it over
time Stallone oh oh yeah and
Schwarzenegger yeah
and possibly Schwarzenegger uh Julia
Roberts Julie Roberts has consistently
made great she's never really like LED
franchises like Tom Cruise has like
Sloan has you know they lead they they I
think but I mean for an actress that is
consistently popular yeah Julia Roberts
um her last film with um George Clooney
I know it's a rom-com but I it's it's my
secret passion don't tell anyone
I did an elevator reaction went and saw
it opening day at like 3 P.M so it was I
was there um
I love this grateful it was so much fun
yeah yeah it's a good film it made me
happy when uh no hard feelings came out
because those are just like I mean we
don't need like the rom-com genre
reinvigorated or anything but we do need
comedy reinvigorated and I'm glad those
two have been here to like put funny
things within a good little romance
whatever but no hard feelings
particularly was just great
yeah I did enjoy that I did enjoy that
uh
oh anyway
you don't like the crashing cars I don't
like the new crashing cars as much but I
love the old crashing cars Bob yeah I
don't think he's I tell you if Vin
Diesel carries on doing what he's doing
and we get to like Fast and the Furious
20. and he carries on doing this for the
next 15 years I'd go yeah
Dwayne Johnson if he cares on doing what
he's doing for the next 15 years yeah
but that's what I mean these Dwayne
Johnson Jason Momoa these actors they've
got to continue they've got a
consistently carry on doing a Vin Diesel
I've got consistently doing what they're
doing for the next 20 years to compare
to I think um Johnny Depp and Tom Hanks
that those are both good shouts yeah
those kind of fit in that same thing
didn't have a franchise but he's
freaking Woody that that just completely
just blew out great movies I mean I see
a few great movies I'd actually argue
Johnny Depp is basically made
four or five really big budget great
movies and he's done a load and load of
really good Indie movies but he's not in
the same categories Tom Cruise for
success
nobody mentioned Samuel Jackson who is
isn't he technically the most successful
actor in history
that would make sense I mean he's he's
in everything he's good friends with
everybody and he just has like a cameo
here or like big part here decent part
here big part here he's everywhere I
think it's like the movie sees appeared
in because it's like the Star Wars the
Marvels and every other bloody film he's
ever appeared I think he's made the
potentially made the most money of any
actor Ever the only other person
well yeah no he'd have to the only
brother person I could think that comes
to mind would be Zoe Saldana and that's
just because of the the franchises she
ends up like finding herself in yeah
yeah but then I've seen Samuel Jackson's
doing all of that well um
um but yeah is um between the prequels
and and other and other things I guess
he's done that probably makes not
necessarily as much money as the avatars
but there's only two avatars there's
always that not on catch up but
good little battle there yeah this this
cracked me up real quick before we jump
back to Tom Cruise I love the Futurama
references you know I do it's the
greatest movie ever made for me so
um
I'm so pumped but what realistically uh
all these like just like comparisons
aside and all that like what are you
thinking with because I love the Mission
Impossible movies I I do obviously I'm
gonna assume but assuming makes an ass
out of you and me so so do that if
necessary uh that you're more of a bond
guy being UK no no wait
um I I love the Giants I love the James
Bond movies but generally the first
James Bond movie out of every new James
Bond is great golden eye great
um Casino Royale great and then they
tend to go
um into silliness like Quantum assalis
and all these others so they're not
consistently good movies and I actually
generally find the Bond movies to be a
bit too long generally and a bit of
their own ass so I enjoy a Bond movie
especially the late ones
yeah
um and oh even the originals even the
Sean Connor is and stuff they're too
long
then
great movies don't get me wrong but the
mission impossible is to me
um
they're a bit more fun
they're they're obviously a lot more
action I do think
three and four wandered a bit I'm not
sure they were great
but only because I tell you what I can I
know sorry yeah three and four I think
because I can't really tell you what
happens in them off top of my head
um Tandy Newton was in the second one
wasn't she when he had the long hair and
like that yeah so I know that that's a
great film the phone and then when it
came back with like
um ghosts
yeah the first one's Ghost Protocol and
that's where my brain
and that that when it really kicked off
and the last ones have been astonishing
um so I mean
um I I would rather sit and watch one of
these movies than watch
um a Bond film if I'm honest
great
well no I I Adore James Bond stuff and
it's always great but I'm such a a
narrative junkie I just like the
chronology of things you know I I my
brain likes to put things in order and
follow that and to be able to do that
with Mission Impossible and like have
that clear narrative from beginning to
end and not kind of have to guess is is
all this in the same world is James Bond
just a a faux name is it is it just
handed on and then that kind of is a
bigger question now that the newest uh
James Bonds out because there was
another 007 but not James Bond so it's
kind of Dr Noah's perfect now he's
perfect no notes none none whatsoever oh
real quick just while we're before that
thought goes away from that previous
thought Denzel dips in and out of action
movies and he is
fantastic two guns with Mark Wahlberg
and maybe one of my favorite films ever
made I love it man on fire might be my
favorite Denzel movie
um he's a phenomenally good actor
um there's a little thing if you want to
know about me personally I'm not a big
crier right I don't I don't really cry a
great deal I think I can on one hand I
can count these out of times I've cried
in my entire life Tom Cruise has done it
to me twice I've had him five times no
sorry not Tom Cruise Tom Hanks twice
so out of five twice is down to Tom
Hanks and one is Denzel Washington so
the one is you know Saving Private Ryan
and it's the beach scene at the start no
no sorry did it to me twice in one movie
and I'm going to count it as once
um at the start of the movie I nearly
cried when he's on the beach instead of
going oh and at the end when
um mark
the other one Ryan actually turns into
an old man and he turns to his like wife
and goes am I a good man tell me I'm a
good man and I'm gonna
so Tom Hanks films did and Philadelphia
with Denzel Washington when he stands on
Washington the first time and then I've
got affiliation for coming over we're
just thinking about it it goes in and it
means for the first time in Denzel
Washington actually like wipes his hand
on his thing after shaking his hands
he's so he's not really sure how to
react I think he says I can't help you
Tom Hanks walks downstairs stands in the
doorway all the people walking by the
Philadelphia music kicks off for the
first time and he just stands there and
Tom Hanks just looks
destroyed and I'm like a top actually
come here
it makes me happy that three out of the
five times you have cried a bit of
movies though
yeah I know one of the fourth times the
fourth time was as well
the fourth time was watching The
Elephant Man
oh okay and I cried my eyes now all the
way through that film and my mom would
not let me go to bed I was only little I
was not I was probably about 10 or 12 or
something and I just it just absolutely
broke my heart that fell I can't watch
it man I can't watch it it is great but
it is one of those films that like you
don't it's not necessarily like
Schindler's List in in like a lot of
ways of course but it's like Schindler's
listing like yeah I've watched it once
I'm okay it's like we're maybe like
again it's fine but once a decade or
something yeah don't know why I don't
know why it upset me so much but it
absolutely honestly like properly like
crying all the way through it's
beautiful well I am your exact tonal
opposite I'm it's not I'm not devoid of
emotions in real life at all obviously
you see me I'm a very emotive person but
I don't tend to cry often yeah and then
I get into a movie theater and have you
seen marriage story
with uh Adam Driver and uh scarjo
yep so you know the atom Driver Line
where he's talking to his kid and he's
like how many times did you cry in that
movie I counted five for me that's me I
I am a baby when I the second I sit down
and like devote my full attention to
something I'm like I'm just a baby I I
revert to a toddler and I I will cry
over to someone being sweet over to
another person but in real life I'm I am
very emotive and I don't tend to cry
often
you get me in a movie
for
and I don't know I love movies now my
goal is
I've got people that I love die and I've
not been upset since I was watching like
in Philadelphia
but uh that was just fat take all over
my keyboard
um shortcut is thrown in are we talking
about Bond and these then where do the
Bourne movies sit because the Bourne
movies out bonded Bond
oh totally totally
I
I and realistically I know Tom Cruise is
in great shape so he he's probably like
the best out of everybody that just
generally to continue on that Legacy
because Bond's just going to continue
being younger people younger people
younger people gonna deal
but Matt Damon is is in shape he could
do it he could continue I can't even
speak he could continue and keep on with
Mission not Mission Impossible born
excuse me uh
easily honestly that that'd be easy and
not only him but Jeremy well Jeremy
Renner might not be able to do it as
well as he could have two years ago
um you might have a limp
he did the hit by a.m snow plaque so I'm
mentioning like I don't I'm not big fan
of Jeremy Runner really
I know it's a weird thing to look at but
when I'm watching him in a film I really
liked him in the first couple of them in
Marvel's don't get me wrong but when I
watched him in the movie I'm like
where's your chin Jeremy you lose it
absolutely don't you
yeah
oh the the people coming up with good
ideas born right Queen
I think all the I generally think the
first born movie in particular
outbonded bond by a mile
it was so
well done it was perfectly done
um right actor right tone
it's just brilliant one of the one of
the best car chases I mean it's like top
five car chases like ever you know you
got like um that um oh what's it called
the bank Job movie with um the Italian
drum no well The Italian Job yeah you
could argue that no I was thinking it
was a really good one with um Robert De
Niro and it's um it was all with Al
Pacino in as well
he he oh man that was a that was a car
chasing and then obviously going back to
like the classics
um like a bullet not happy but the the
mini car chase scene in in
um in the first Bourne movie was just
phenomenal no CGI they actually just
[__] did it
it's part of my French
they just did it we're in Cuban we we
can use this kind of language but also
we are sidetrackers
yes
see you next Tuesday I mentioned that on
stream yesterday and I'm glad we didn't
actually say it because it was being
stormy so words could go anywhere on
that stream don't push anything with um
Harris you're on the wrong Channel
apparently so just remind people while
they're watching please go and subscribe
to Harris's Channel who is actually that
way not that way on M3 there should be
links in the description we're having a
little bit of fun to um try and push
some love towards the young man because
you know his beard deserves it
he doesn't disappeared well that's okay
I'm happy I still have it and I have to
have it for at least another month or
two so for this movie so
I can't grow once if I think if I turn
up for a movie role and they go score a
beard come back in a month I'll be going
well I may as well come back in 10 years
because it's not happening
that's why they shave shave hair and put
it on beard beard things and stick
stickers don't be honest it's so intense
those things but
There's the link hey
there we go uh but yeah
class promotion everywhere you're a
messed up uh and and honestly y'all are
on M Cube fairly frequently now so y'all
gotta come say howdy just uh whenever
Jay and Matt are coming to hang out too
so yep y'all know we do this a couple of
times a week now stormy was on your
channel last night and I I haven't
watched it yet but apparently it was um
a little bit rambunctious is a fantasy
with stormy behaving we're a tad bit
rambunctious we we did go I think two
hours ten minutes something like that so
we were having some fun did you try to
finish after 45 minutes the storm just
wouldn't like me because that's what it
keeps doing to me no no he he gave his
full plan out uh on on the stream uh he
said every time we hit an hour on
Sidetrack he's like okay I got a half
hour
we're ready
he does it to me every time
but um I I we love him very much
of course
but I I
Tom Cruise continuing with Mission
Impossible because Mission Impossible
has felt like
they they care more about it the further
it goes along we're we're Bond they
definitely care about it all the time
always they've that that's where I would
separate it with Bourne where uh I think
someone said yeah David said earlier uh
howdy by the way that uh the Third born
movie after it kind of went downhill and
I'd agree I don't dislike the uh the the
uh born legacy with Jeremy Renner and I
don't dislike the uh
look at that complete Muppet in the
middle there beautiful beautiful
uh uh oh God I almost said it uh what is
what is it uh laser laser-eyed dinosaurs
whatever I'm I try to say it right I
couldn't say it right laser shooting
dinosaurs laser shooting dinosaurs there
we go that that's the raucous that
happened after you left last time Jay
uh but but yeah I I would I would out of
the three kind of like super big spy
franchises
I would think that mission impossible is
poised to continue further born's
probably poised just as much to do that
just they haven't had the same box
office success they haven't had the same
amount of films and uh they kind of have
I don't think they've gotten bad by any
uh means but they they haven't been as
solid as those first three particularly
the first two the the last born movie
The Third born movie I apologize I
forget the names of them all to be
honest you come away from it and I was
thinking I'm not sure what happened
the story lines of of things because
it's a mission based things like each
one has been I mean I know there's been
some some carry on with the story
generally speaking it's a mission
mission
um with the Bourne movies they were into
try but I have to admit I'm not 100 what
happened in the third one somewhere
they're going what what was really I
don't really get why who's that why is
that and you shouldn't come away from a
film sort of not quite understanding
what's happened so I would say the first
born movie was an instant classic I'm
not for sure about the rest
see I like the second almost just as
much but the the third I think is where
it falters and then the just the Jason
Bourne the technical fourth one that's
not with uh Jeremy Renner that one that
one really throws me off uh I I couldn't
tell you anything about it besides Tommy
Lee Jones is there and I think I've
probably watched it three or four times
and I still don't really remember it you
know
um absolutely right you should you
shouldn't come away from a film years
later and go walk into that filming like
no yeah especially if you've seen it
more than once you know like Tommy Lee
Jones and Matt Damon
and I think that the the what one of the
blonde actresses from one of the first
movies came back so that's like all I
remember that is
in that yeah I remember her Blondie
um she's lovely
[Music]
um
is that where it was from Matt
it's not from Kung Fury no it's Angus
book six Angus mix six that's right
because you said MC5
confused great it's so good
every part of my being except for this
part I'm this big little bit in my brain
that is still
um about four years old the rest of my
body went this is stupid don't like it
but the little part of my brains they're
going love this so much it's so good
looking it's true I love it so stupid
but anyway but stupidly perfect
but um if we talk about the deadline
just we've talked about the deadline
thing talking about how much does
deadline actually own shares in the
Mission Impossible movies
because they freaking love this film
that's true I mean I mean they love this
film as much as I love my wife covered
in squirty cream naked on the floor with
I mean that's how much they love this
film I really love this film I mean
they're throwing cherries on it they're
you know they're they're all ready to go
[Music]
um
so what any reason for that where'd the
background go well oh I was gonna bring
up the article that we're talking about
okay here we are I think I don't know
how it looks on here though there we go
uh that's what I was trying to figure
out but yeah no no they gush about it
like like we were talking about earlier
there are like we have four different
reviews technically about this to go
over variety deadline collider and The
Hollywood Reporter and each one kind of
says similar but different things and
each one is like very particular
deadline just gushes over it they that
what you you were surprised I didn't I
skimmed through the article I read it
entirely different and then you pointed
this out
the combined budget between part one and
part two of I guess Mission Impossible 7
or is it Mission Impossible seven and
eight I don't really know how they're
classifying it uh is 828 million
freaking dollars and they expect it to
make three and a half billion
Matt just you were in here for that
conversation earlier what is your
initial thought there
yay nay is that gonna happen
they expect it to make three and a half
billion
[Music]
five billion each so Avatar money
for both
um
[Music]
Tom Cruise I don't know you could he
could it's Tom Cruise but it's it's I
don't know
well I think since covid how many movies
have made
over one and a half billion dollars Top
Gun was a bit of a special case because
it was more of a
um
[Music]
yeah it was like uh not a reboot as such
but like uh this Nostalgia a nostalgic
[__] kind of thing yeah
whereas the mission impossible has been
going forever so
I mean I don't know Avatar as well how
long was it between the two Avatar
movies
20 years so I mean 13 years okay well
people were desperate to see it they
were ridiculously desperately and that
just adminster Lake in the end it wasn't
two billion was it I think it might be
oh no it was it was over 2 billion it
was like 2.5
one four 2.4 billion something like that
because
2.3
all right
this is the third the highest gross but
what's 100 million between friends right
yeah yeah 2.3 billion so I mean it's got
to do way of it's got to do nearly
fat money
um I I just I can't see it in the
current climate where we've got an
Indiana Jones film which again people
were excited about and everyone was
saying this is amazing and it's just
about made 100 million now
in a week and and that was July 4th
weekend uh-huh so it had five days to do
it it ain't 85 million dollars in the US
over a four day weekend five day weekend
which which two two it's the history or
not but has to its benefit at least it
was projected to make 82.5 so it made
just a tad more than we expected and we
all thought it was going to make a lot
less so that that's kind of nice at
least but
is it gonna make that budget back I
always do with me because I've been
crying and slitting my wrist and trying
to jump off a building right now
um are we can't even make an Indiana
Jones movie that people like what what's
the point in my existence it's just I
don't know I think that's terrible it's
not going to make its money it's going
to lose money hand over fist yeah well I
I was there I had a similar sort of
budget two to three hundred million
dollars yes
this this might even have a higher
budget so it kind of needs to make its
money back in a lot of ways
anybody can do it it's James Cameron or
Tom Cruise or maybe even Sam Jackson
those are probably like honestly the
three people that can bring anybody to a
movie theater screen but Sam Jackson not
even everybody's watching secret
Invasion right now I've only seen half
of the first episode like
you know I don't know if you could even
bring that draw at the moment which is
just odd to think about I might have
forgotten about it a little bit I forgot
I watched the first episode and I might
forgotten about it but I started
watching which which is
so good
um so I forgot all about it I'll tell
you what this this movie might be the
end or break apparently
and they're in some serious Financial
stuck at the moment and
this this film could either save them or
kill them do you think Paramount would
put more money into it to try to make
sure it's successful and do you think
that's actually a good idea or not
because they do have Tom Cruise to
promote and he's he is a a brand unto
himself
he's now he wasn't five years ago but
he's not again his popularity was
weighing in quite dramatically a couple
of years ago
back at the top of his game again
um
[Laughter]
no not really
have you seen any of the mission
Impossibles
I've got a phone call he's like let me
check uh
I'll be back in a sec all right oh yeah
I generally thought that was a bit to
get out of answering the question
um I honestly think if they lose money
on this the financial position they're
in at the moment Paramount
um I mean there are some arguments to
say that actually
um
that
um top um Top Gun saved them that they
were in real trouble and Top Gun
well in a bit of breathing room
they didn't just say or Tom Cruise and
Top Gun didn't just say Paramount
Spielberg you think Tom Cruise for
saving movies that was a big thing a
couple months ago
gave him a phone call and was like thank
you for for literally not just saving
like the Blockbuster but but saving
movies after the pandemic and everything
and that man
Mr Odin and I don't know who the big
Cinema was it's AMC or something in in
the US in the Big Cinema chains but um
Mr Odin and Mr AMC should be on their
knees
tickling from cruises anywhere he likes
and thank him because realistically I I
I don't I think avatar The Wave water
was going to be hugely successful one
way or another but I don't know if it
would be as successful as it was if top
gun Maverick wasn't as successful as it
was because that ended up being the
movie that people were like oh [__]
maybe I should go back to the movie
theaters excuse my French of course but
uh well you know it brought people okay
maybe maybe we can go sit next to people
in a crowded area again
cost of living crisis and the cinema is
expensive yep not cheap
um I got two kids we went to watch
Indiana Jones at the weekend and it
costs by the time they've had a bloody
map shows which they incestor now in
we've spent 100 quid
like 20 quarter ticket 10 quid for their
things it's like 100 pounds gone
um it kind of amazed me as when I first
moved out to LA I think I showed you I
was like 250 pounds I was a hell of a
lot heftier than I am now and uh
I would of course go to the movie
theaters all the time I always go to the
movie theaters all the time but like the
expensive fancy food that I try to buy
to be healthy and Bs happy birthday
armadillo uh on the piano just to move
on the inside but crunch on the outside
armadillos
um sorry that's another animal
Diamond bars they're crunchy on the
inside is smooth on the outside but
armadillos for the other way around
and British people will get what the
hell I'm talking about no one else but I
don't care I have no idea but I have
some funny armadillo stories that I
probably shouldn't tell out on here
they're not bad but you know publicly
just we don't have them
but uh uh
armadrants as far as I could turn
they're gorgeous they're beautiful
little creatures they're like they're
land turtles without being tortoises
okay okay
uh
where were we again uh
the title of this though makes it
interesting to me and I just think I
think that is a big problem with cinema
right now yes CGI is a huge problem
cinema right now
it's it's overuse
it I mean just one Trope that's been
used way too often in in everything has
been
third act giant CGI Sky beam everyone
has to save things from coming out of
the sky beam or or save things from
going into the sky beam whatever it may
be it's oh God it's everywhere and
yeah if it's not that it's just a
general CGI uh crap Fest uh for lack of
a better terminology where you might
have like Shang Chi's the first thing
that comes to mind is where I do really
thoroughly enjoy the first two acts and
they're not perfect I I I would like a
little bit of a difference in the way
they they continue on with that kind of
stuff of course but that third act it's
it's not bad I like the con like the
implications of it but I just don't like
the way it was executed at all because
you're like Aquafina shooting bows and
arrows she wasn't good with the bow and
arrow 20 minutes ago and now CGI things
are flying everywhere so anytime she
shoots in the air excellent now it's
giant CGI you don't you can't really
tell what's going on half the time
Transformers ride the rise of the Beast
I thoroughly enjoyed even the third Act
of that but whenever you get into the
fight sequences it's a gray background
versus robots and and what color are
robots silver and gray all the
Transformer movies has been the same
though they're so you know I think I
think I've pitched about this before but
the editing and whatever on the on them
is just horrible I hate Michael base the
way he edits movies
um it's not even edited badly like that
it's just it's just the way
the way it is they chose to do it yeah I
don't know I mean you can't really argue
about CGI in a Transformers movie though
because they're not they can't build
Transformers they just can't however
which you want them to they can't the
way they use it and the some of the
stumps and things they do is then
ridiculous I mean I've said to you
before and I we I play a game with my
kids how many times do those people
definitely have died and when we're
watching Transformers movie we're up to
like 112 in like the first 20 minutes
because they that would definitely break
that person's spine like anytime like a
giant robot catches you like it's still
you're falling onto a giant chunk of
metal like
untransforms and they sort of Fallout
and he sort of catches them and then
lands and they're going well that person
is dead he's just he's landed into a
massive metal hand it's like in the
ground he's dead but just slightly
better than like falling on asphalt and
sliding a bit you know like I'd honestly
rather the ass button get a bounce fear
that is okay it's when they it's when
it's every couple of minutes so when he
goes again this is you know it's not
when the faster the forest movies you
know they had a few ridiculous things in
the early movies and they were just sort
of like yeah but that's okay A bit of
fun and then by the ninth movie like
really
um space and they're going to drive
through a satellite and they got it
yeah um but this idea though
are you're on to something my man that
that's that would get an R8 that that
would be great Optimus Prime you [__]
because Guy Richie
only does he tends to do heist movies of
some sort like everything at least has
like a heist to a degree
which could so totally work his latest
film I mean he did that um Covenant on
what was it Amazon
with him Jake Gyllenhaal
the theaters I loved it it's an army
movie when the basically a great film
and um really powerful as well and then
before that he did the one with um he
did oh I forgot what it's called but
it's um
no no no no no no he did uh uh uh uh uh
no uh Fortune the ruse or something like
that yeah great brilliant film gentleman
before that brilliant can't watch it
with my wife because she hates the c
word and every other word is he took out
the and put in
see what we can't say
um
why did they cancel Paramount instead of
Transformers Earth spark I don't know
they just hate Star Trek and they're
getting ready to sell it possibly and
they probably want to boost Transformers
as much as possible because I will put
this up real fast
for the new uh Transformers at least
did you see it do you care
not really uh it ends with GI Joe like
like they introduced GI Joe into
Transformers at the end
they want to kind of like bolster
everything up as much as they can well
the GI Joe attempt to franchise
went so badly wrong the first one was
fun I like the first one that's I I
thought the second one would have been
better if they'd have kept
um
um but they didn't
um and they thought well we'll do for
the rock they should have had the Rock
and Shannon James it would have been
awesome yeah no no that would have been
an excellent just co-starring capability
there uh
and they obviously I still haven't
watched Snake Eyes that was another
failed attempt at rebooting GI Joe uh
and it just died
watched about 10 minutes of it and um
and got distracted by watching the grass
grow outside
look at that grass that's going
fascinating little wind blow
um but no it's terrible I get I honestly
I watched about 20 minutes of it and
it's just like this is just nonsense
it's just nonsensical
um but um but yeah so I could see that
they're going to try to
reboot it makes some sense Marvel Comics
OG Comics were the best GI Joe ever old
GI Joe like that the I don't know about
the Earth spark or whatever that
animated show was but it's terrible hey
it wasn't good it's weeds big chin
Transformers which is strange that's
that's not the animated movie that Chris
Hemsworth is gonna voice off is it
serious okay okay okay uh because I I
I'd like for them to bring back some of
that 80s kind of feel to it and that
would make sense and kind of bringing
that GI Joe that Transformers
correlation together in that way
is but like we talked about the other
day franchise fatigue is it too much of
something and and do people even want
more of it or do they want something new
and if they are going to get something
it has to be good or people are just
gonna get continuously pissed off
the the problem I'm saying I don't think
there is
a franchise critique I don't think it
exists
I I honestly think
if you've got good films people are
watching
um I think what like we said the other
day it's it's it's produced a fatigue
it's the people making it I think they
get bored and yeah and get ready I mean
you can argue this with Stargate
um I was talking about this in the video
today you're planning an interview well
yeah why did they do this to you
um and I said in the argument I
genuinely think they try to do something
different and and talking to Brad right
and listen what Brad Wright said about a
few times
I think there wasn't an element of MGM
pushing for it but I think it was
element of proud writers desperately
wanted to do something different
yeah and
um but they weren't equipped to do it
and and that's not disembrad right or
anyone else
they just had never done that sort of
series before and it took them a little
while to get their foot in
by the second that's why I think the
second series is so much better because
they were they'd figured out the tone
and they'd figured out how to do it and
stuff and and that's the problem is if
you've got makers if they don't do
something different if they don't try
and freshen it up they get they're human
beings at the end of the day and I think
they get a bit bored
um and then you start getting bad TV or
they get lazy or they do what the SGU
did and they try to force is to keep
themselves interested in a way but that
kind of backfires because then the fans
don't like it so much and so I mean it's
like you but but I've always said though
you're damned if you're doing damage if
you don't yeah you had just been another
version of sg1 or SGA people are going
oh there we go again doing the same
thing again
but they did something different and
everyone was sort of like whoa why is it
different what are you doing so you
sometimes it doesn't matter what you do
you're going to be wrong
which which you made a good point about
in your video and then Joe Flanagan uh
kind of of course made the point
originally in the in the shuttlepod
podcast but
it would have been nice to have kept SGA
and allowed it to survive two more
seasons or something along along those
lines another season maybe even
coinciding with SGU which would have not
pitted them against each other and
pitted the cast against each other the
production Productions even against each
other it would have been able to cross
over a little bit more because they did
cross over with sg1 but not SGA and SGA
was the show that was still on air at
the time or right
and just left air and was more fresh in
people's minds as well so
obviously I'm late in the game for this
and I'm just doing thinking about all
this 10 years 12 years after it actually
happened but
that would have just made more sense and
and I I feel like Transformers could uh
screw themselves up if
if they do something like that without
uh
really you know not necessarily Bridging
the Gap but just making sure everything
correlates in a good way and and the
producers aren't bored and and that's
probably the thing that like the last
the third Act of the movie I don't think
the producers felt bored but it just
didn't feel as creative in a lot of ways
because I thought Iron Man was popping
out in the end of Transformers but it
ended up being more GI Joe suit kind of
things obviously it's neither of those
things but
it's reminiscent of both and and that
kind of uh
doesn't doesn't shine on their
creativity where Transformers could
easily be creative in a lot of different
ways that didn't feel like it was
bringing something new to the table
which kind of hurt and instead of trying
to bring something new to the table and
not like working uh like SGU it was kind
of uh
pigeonholed shoehorned you know just
kind of been there for the sake of it
instead of trying to like up the ante
because bumblebee up the ante I I really
enjoy Bumblebee as a movie I think it's
probably the best Transformers movie I
had mixed
that's fair it is I actually I enjoyed
it more than I thought I was great it's
it's
well it's it's the best movie out of the
Transformers movies I don't know if it's
the best Transformers movie if that
makes sense
I really liked sgu's World Trevor uh
we're just kind of talking about how it
how it didn't necessarily start off the
best way especially by pitting
everybody against each other and I hope
the GI Joe Transformer stuff isn't pit
against each other as well because if
one starts to do better than the other
and if they do do a GI Joe movie based
off of Anthony Ramos's character I there
are so many different things that could
happen uh
and damned if they do damned if they
don't like I said well we'll have to
wait and see and and it just depends on
if we're willing to go support that or
not in movie theaters of course I'll
keep talking about it of course but uh
we'll see we'll see what general
audiences go and see if Matt's excited
about something that means we know we
should all be excited about something
that's that's particularly A good rule
of thumb there
uh
there was like this to you I like the
second season of SG I didn't like the
first season but anyway I like both but
I'm I'm I just I don't know
I like spaceships this though
I've got faith and I've got worries uh
on both sides for the new avatar Last
Airbender I mean okay I love what I'm
wearing
I'm literally wearing an uncle iro shirt
right now surprise jasmine tea uh I love
me avatar The Last Airbender I've got
four posters like like Well Done drawed
drawing posters uh that were made and I
got them at La Comic Con two years ago I
think yeah two years ago not last year
and I just need the frame to put them up
on the wall back here because that's
what's going to be back here is uh
avatar The Last Airbender stuff
eventually
thank you
but I I worry I worry we will we will
cover that as it comes out so good
the cartoon right I love the original
cartoon
um I argue that it's the best thing ever
made per capita
um
because I've seen other things but
but it was good I mean it's no Futurama
good but it was it was good
um I did enjoy it I loved it the movie
was
um
awful yeah it was it was badly
it was badly conceived from the
beginning it was it was it was a bad
idea they're spending 15 million dollars
an episode on this series
um so the craters were there to help
plan things out at least they have them
in their wild production's been going on
but the original creators were there
wild things were being planned whether
they continued and helped some of the
actual scripting and then production
aspects
we'll find out
but it's nice that Brian Brian uh
Michael Dante di Martino and Brian
kametsko uh I have to always say in that
order right or throw myself off
but I I'm glad they're part of it and um
to a degree not necessarily a part of it
now but
I don't know
are you more excited for that are you
more excited for uh the the two creators
doing Avatar Studios for Nickelodeon and
Paramount that's that's Avatar is
Paramount sneak thing right there they
have again on Netflix so much
I think the Netflix thing would be good
uh
for me the couple of things that come to
Netflix the moment I am looking forward
to Last Airbender I'm really hoping they
get on with the He-man live action movie
which I He-Man was my my cartoon when I
was a kid
freaking loved it I think Kevin Smith
has heard the possibilities of a
live-action He-Man movie unfortunately
um as far as I know
it's not gone into film and it was
supposed to so I need to I need to go
and have a check again but I'm dying for
that
um but Netflix are on a on and up at the
moment and Netflix are doing well again
um you know they've had they've had a
couple of years struggling and they've
really kicked it on again I think we're
going to talk about a bit later on so um
so
yeah I I think it's going to be good I
think it will be a damp site better than
Amazon's rings of power and
um but at the end of the day
um yes please no we should play orca
let's play Orca that'd be great
um but um on my arms obviously Jack
Black's man at Arms
and that'd be good
um but
yeah it's just
I tell you the thing with Last Airbender
I'll be excited when I see the advert
and then I'll get excited and at the
moment yeah I'm I'm still there thinking
that's a lot of money and and
unfortunately
they've got the rings of power problem
because I think people stamped on rings
of power immediately because of how much
money it costs
nothing else mattered even the woke it's
were like
but they spent a billion dollars and
went you know crazy yeah Solomon's twist
that was this charlemen ruined it yeah I
really like some of this stuff I think
he's does some very very clever movies
and that thing he did with um Dave
Batista recently and with the suicide
thing oh man it was a good film
Dave Batista is such a good actor Jesus
um
you know so um yes that worked
um but
yeah um yeah I mean he just he ruined it
he tried to do an action movie there's
not he's sort of move and he's gone back
to doing what he's just right
I love some nights but uh that one may
be one of the worst movies ever made
that or The Happening those both those
both can take the cake for for God I
didn't hate the happening I've just
spent the whole time going what's
happening and then that was the point
um but uh yeah it was all of his films
you come away go in
I I either love that or hate it I can't
make my mind well as of Reason like like
knock at the cabin and even old I that's
those are the first two movies I haven't
either loved or hated from him I've been
like those were pretty damn good I
didn't love them but I really enjoyed
them in their own ways I hated The Sixth
Sense
um but I know I'm the only one but my
girlfriend at the time the the cow who I
now hate
um
no no she told me the twisters
very pretty girl but she told me the
twist so I hate her
um so I'm watching the movie all the way
through him going [__] ghost oh like
this
um and and it just ruined the film for
me oh I mean that makes sense she's a
cow just for that that she gets that
science was good I really like science
the scientist right um but it's okay
because a few years later she died so
it's fine she didn't she's fine okay I
was like damn damn year ago only the
only the kid can only the kid from the
movie can see you now
Haley Joel Osmond who's now in the well
no no he died in the boys too oops
but no she's fine um I bet I should
probably check she's fine yeah you're
like now
don't manifest bad things for that lady
or maybe because she did rules you're
still alive
yeah she's fine
um so real quick you want to just finish
out uh just talking about just we can
even just go over the headlines
realistically because those are really
what the bulk of these things tend to be
about uh
Hollywood Reporter says the story second
uh secondary and the action is the big
primary like focus on Mission Impossible
7 which
I might be okay with if the second half
of the movie really like picks up on the
story I I much prefer story and uh
especially when it works and coincides
well with action which I feel it has in
the last couple uh
Mission Impossible and John Wick more so
than like any other thing just in recent
memory that action's gone so well with
story and
I hope that continues obviously it may
not with this uh I I tend to trust what
Hollywood Reporter thinks about a lot of
things so
hopefully hopefully they got the money
on the head uh or hit the nail on the
head there but
we'll have to see and we'll see very
soon which is great stories should
create the action
spoken like a true movie lover thank you
thank you
uh we got one more little article here
it's the collider article which they
loved it they're another they were
gushing about it they they said Tom
Cruise does take a so they're kind of
like with The Hollywood Reporter they it
seems like Tom Cruise is seemingly like
taking a little bit of a step back in
this thing to kind of let everybody else
shine uh which means that story might
suffer a little bit because of that but
that that also keeps my hopes up for the
second part and it's like okay if they
did want to do this in two separate
parts part of that might be because the
first half of it was more
gritty action Boom Boom Pow kind of
stuff in the second half of it might be
uh it ain't gonna be a slow burn that
won't be the right term for it but it
will be hopefully something that
puts that cherry on top from the last
film which is what a second part
typically should do
and and with Tom Cruise and all their
amazing cast Ving Rhames Haley Atwell
and Rebecca Ferguson Simon Pegg et
cetera Etc they're amazing
they also have Ralph Macquarie in in the
director's chair and the writer's chair
I trust Ralph Macquarie with my life
like that yeah you know if Tom Cruise
trusts somebody with his life I'd
probably trust that person with my life
him stepping back a little bit more like
the other country sign that's just an
evolution because that's what they've
been doing more and more
since um Ghost Protocol and the Vince
frames and everyone else Simon Pegg in
particular this character has gone from
a guy stood in the background to a main
character it was like background cue and
now it's even better than two in a lot
of ways
um so that's just uh that's just a
continuation of what they've already
been doing so that doesn't surprise me
in the slightest and I'd say it's a good
thing because it is such a it's a family
cast now oh yeah
um
I saw um Simon Pegg talking about it a
couple of weeks ago and he said it is it
is got to the point where you know
everybody on the you know everybody
you you know I'm saying we see them
think but don't show the production crew
and stuff we know them all we respect we
spent we spent a decade with them now
yeah
Macquarie since Ghost Protocol too right
so it's been at least eight years of
just that same kind of team which is you
know beautiful badass which is another
reason I think why it's better and done
better than sort of like Bond or
whatever because there is that
consistency there there is that team
there and they know what they're doing
they know what different there's nobody
in there going should we do something a
bit different should we shake things up
they're like going no we're doing a
mission impossible movie this is this is
what we do this is what we do right
um and also then you've got to have a
doctor that's going to let
um Tom Cruise do something stupid
um and scare us all to death because
that's gone from straight from the first
one with the one what was his name the
director of the first one
that did the first director the first
one
at least and I think he directed the
first one
Mission impossible's been together as
long as sg1 that's a great freaking
point that is a great point
and that that's what John Wayne directed
the first one John Woo directed it and
De Palma wrote it okay with the um the
drop down bit and the thing he was
saying I would scared him to death
and John we couldn't watch it that's the
only reason I remember I saw an
interview John Williams saying I
couldn't I couldn't I couldn't watch
that the first time I saw that stunt was
at the cinema because I couldn't watch
it
it just scared me to death and how much
money did you just pay to hire this guy
how much money are you paying
to keep this guy and then here he comes
trying to kill himself every single time
he does a stunt and it's just like going
like I'm gonna kill Tom Cruise I'm gonna
kill Tom Cruise and now Robin McCrory is
like go for it bud
yeah God for God guys don't let don't
kill Tom Cruise for the love of God
um yeah maybe maybe kill the Scientology
part but everything else
or hell maybe don't kill the Scientology
part maybe he needs that crazy just to
be able to do all this but who knows who
knows uh I just I guess just uh to bring
the original Point home uh because we
have spent an hour on Tom Cruise and
ancillary Tom Cruise stuff which is kind
of great you know the man deserves it
for bringing back Cinema he brought film
back Spielberg would be proud of this
hour uh do with all of this we just
talked about how excited we are kind of
are for it even though it's not like the
thing that probably sticks out to us
it's still like that subliminal uh high
expectations uh high octane action and
just enjoyability
yeah we know Tom Cruise is willing to
stay in shape we know Tom Cruise is
willing to uh do some cool stuff
although Indiana Jones and the dial
Destiny has a lot of CG Harrison Ford is
shirtlessed in one of the opening scenes
and like the dude's still in shape he's
in his boxers in the scene like he's in
decent shape for an 82-83 year old man
and he can still move around fairly well
for a guy that age as well
if Tom Cruise stays in Tom Cruise shape
20 more years of Mission Impossible
would you would you be in
how old is Tom Cruise now 61.
so we're gonna get an Indiana Jones
style Mission Impossible movie with Joe
no not that I I he just said he wants to
continue doing it until he's Harrison
Ford's age I I I I I
um no
it's honestly even Tom Cruise is gonna
is going to slow down at some point he's
already in his 60s like we said and yes
no he's mental but to be honest at that
age you're only one injure away
from having real problems
um so all right and he has injured
himself badly on some of these movies
was it I think it was the last one was
the one before he shattered his ankle
um fifth one when he's jumping out
across the the building and then it's
still in the movie yeah yeah you can
actually see him shatter his uncle and
you can see his face when he hits the
ground as well because they were like um
I remember the draft is going have you
got another one in you in German no I
think I'm going to be perfectly but
still he's shattered
um so
at some point
all right so okay with with what uh the
collider article said about the
ancillary and secondary cast really
taking like the shine now do you think
it could be possible if he
not necessarily I don't want to say toss
the torch off but allows the the
secondary to really
come up and and get their kind of uh
same same part obviously it'll still be
a Tom Cruise movie most likely but no to
be honest because you know who who in
the cast is young enough
to to do that
um
they'd have to probably
bring somebody else in eventually
with him the British lady's name is
Rebecca Ferguson Rebecca fix I could I
could see I could do a Rebecca fix a
mission impossible spin-off movie I'm
amazing already
Honestly though I like legitimately
she's great did you uh did you see
doctor sleep when it came out yeah yeah
and I've loved her since she did she did
something called the um
the white
the White Queen or something like that
in this country and she's phenomenally
that and she's just she's just so damn
pretty
um side quest says because I'm Jack
Reacher 3 for Tom Cruise he shouldn't
have done Jack Reacher too
I don't know what happened to the budget
on that film that was only it is low air
but I think and I'm not sure they could
get the money for that film so they just
did it
and it it was very clearly didn't have
the budget but to be honest no because
the TV show is so much better
that they should never go back to doing
the film
am I crazy didn't Chris Pine do a Jack
Reacher movie too
yes you're crazy
okay okay I I I don't know what I'm
because oh
you're not thinking you're thinking um
Chris Pine did was it Jack Ryan Jack
Ryan ah okay okay
one of the jacks just as a little thing
would anybody like if we did a show with
maybe one or two the guys off the
shuttle pods show on
because they've offered
so is that a response should I say yes
I I would say hell yes
that would be awesome let's do that
um so they told me off because I'll tell
you what they they've mentioned so
they've they've I said great show guys
and they mentioned oh thank you we loved
your video from earlier
um you'd be great if you threw a link on
for this full video and I'd point out I
already did it's in the description
um but I'll add a comment on
um
I called it the shuttle pod podcast
and um and they would say no we call it
we kind of shows the shuttle pod show
now and I'm like well thank God for that
saying this little pod podcast is really
hard yeah
happy to make myself all the show
available for anything you were doing
someone's gonna think that's an essay
that's a request so
um
let's see if we get one of them on the
show
I'm loving what they're doing so I'd
love to quite apply talk to anyone I do
like Dominic Keating I'm just not as
familiar with the guy because I'm not
the biggest Trekkie in the world but is
it Connor trinier or trinier is his name
I think yep
I mean
he is Michael
he is Michael and to be honest he was
brilliant in Star Trek Enterprise as
well for his trip he was not familiar
with the Star Trek aspect um
he was brilliant as Michael he was great
just well we'll put the bookmark on Tom
Cruise we can pick up on Tom Cruise on
any day I I'm I'm kind of uh iffy on the
dish that's right she is Swedish she's
Swedish yeah she is um the only reason I
keep thinking she's British is because
of that she appeared in that BBC show
when she was quite young and I keep
thinking she's British but she's not
you're actually Swedish does the BBC
pick up people from all across uh Europe
no she was just a British show and she
played
um a British monarch
and it was the first thing I ever saw in
it like white princess a white queen or
something I was called
um and it was just great but no no yeah
she's they are actually Swedish you tell
she's Swedish is oh she looks Swedish
yeah uh yeah but but I I've been down
for 20 more years of mission impossible
as long as they have the story and it
doesn't necessarily need to be Tom
Cruise and Ralph Macquarie but if it was
like
maybe every eight ten years like that
same kind of like
they plan something out and and played
to that plan then I would be okay with
it
besides that I'm I'm with I think Trey
Gage said it earlier was like uh just
just make make individual movies you
know because that's that's good uh
but oh where where did I I wanted to
just to end that and go to the next
thing but I kind of had to laugh at this
real quick she sells seashells by the
seashore podcast
Futurama no I always view drama uh what
happened to David Hewlett I don't know
but uh what were you supposed to order
uh an order were you supposed to uh
interview
I begged
um but no I'm I've got the interview
with um Brent State on uh this is going
to be on the next day or two
um so that's holding on the unedited
video I Threw on patreon yesterday so it
goes on patreon.com can see that
um and Brent state if you don't know the
name he he played for ready in Stargate
sg1 and he played rev bam in Andromeda
and he's been in a million other things
as well so he was that was a fascinating
conversation I really enjoyed talking to
him so that should be on tomorrow after
this I've got to record an intro for it
and then my internet's going again so go
get another Rider
um but um I've just got to record a
little intro for it and then that'll be
on tomorrow for you guys and then I have
sent those the the podcast guys a
message just go and I'd love to have any
of you on
please
please thank you
um but but yeah
um
but yeah
um right I approached who I thought was
to live Flanigan and it turned out to be
a con artist but I have spoken to a
couple of people about July Flanagan and
apparently you you have to do it through
his agent
um and I have to admit I have made a
request
um so
um I would love to get somebody like Joe
flanagano because he's honest you won't
get any [__] from a man and he will
tell you exactly what you think and I
would love
to have that opportunity to give him
a platform where he can say whatever he
wants
um
and but I have to admit in the Jolly
Flanagan interview I pulled back from it
because he started talking about how
Brad Wright wasn't really happy with
Richard Dean Anderson at one point and
towards the end of the video and after I
started to get a bit uh I'm not sure
jokes you should be sharing that because
one you're telling everybody else what
Brad Wright thinks that's not ideal
and the other thing is
I I actually know that there that wasn't
quite the relationship
so
um
Chris judge I have a possible aim with
Christians
so that's possible
I've just got to be really really nice
to the person that's my possible in and
that is it's a very big maybe
um but it's possible
so I'm going to be trying
um and as normal if anybody has any
ideas to have to do this because I'm an
amateur I don't know what I'm doing
um I have no freaking quote
um so anybody has any ideas how to do
things like that for the channel
I'm all he is because I don't know so
but I'm doing my best I have a couple of
options yeah help me and but the thing
is the channel is getting to a size now
where people are starting to notice us
which is nice so we are looking a little
bit more credibility we're getting a
little bit more people are actually
taking us a little bit more seriously
and we there are there are options for
these things
I feel like sidetracks had like the
general street cred for a while and then
then Jenny kind of helped on the the one
podcast by by giving a little more
credit credibility there and uh
at this point you're just making it
beautiful every day every week
I still got called a liar constantly but
it's nice and I get called a liar and
then I sort of but I get called lying on
the most random videos I got called a
liar loads you know the video I did
actually I did on on for the last um
short pod oh no no it was an interview
it was the guy from um
uh sg1 who I kept calling Dave and his
name isn't Dave for I kept calling him
Brian or something anyway and he was in
SGU and uh and there was him saying I
know they're making a bunch of movies so
I did a video on that going because you
know that's what we've been talking
about thank you track okay that's
amazing that's the last time I see
um so I did a video saying
this is what he said and I still gotta
call the liar no way you're like I'm
quoting the guy like
um but the problem is if you're saying
stuff that no one else is saying because
I know a couple of sources where or
whatever you know even if it's stuff
that makes complete sense somebody will
still call your eye but that's YouTube
yeah well I mean
through Garfield talking about
Spider-Man
he had a lie all the time and it's not
like you're not actually lying or
anything he just had to withhold that's
a whole different I guess situation but
like you know people can call you later
no matter what you do you could be
completely telling the truth or
completely like fabricating something
and no matter what you will be called a
liar and other people completely believe
you uh and you know all y'all got to do
in the comment section is tell us your
opinions and thoughts and then let time
unfold
um but if you don't like the channel and
you and you just want to come in and
slags off do us a favor and [__] off
I'm not really that bothered
I I generally have people that subscribe
and watch the videos I swear to God all
they do is they subscribe and wait for a
video to come up so they can hit the ban
because I've got two or three people
that any video I put on when I have
three down likes within two minutes and
I'm like well you have no time to watch
the video
sometimes
so I'm just like those guys can
okay I was like yeah I almost didn't say
in a couple different Channel names but
I am they would have been jokes they
might bring us some heat never mind
never mind I was joking mentally
um yeah I've got better things to do
than live but the nice thing is now I've
got to a point where I don't thank you
thanks Rich I don't stress it
um it is normal Channels with a million
subscribers and loads of credibility and
stuff still people going on they're
going you're talking [__] and you're
just making stuff up and they get the
worst yeah
it's it's not worth stressing over I I
will make content I will talk about
stuff I enjoy
and if other people want to watch it as
well great
I don't know if you saw this but
Kowalski might be a possibility huh we
might try to find Kowalski and again I
might have an in
so
um I I I may have somebody that could
possibly get me in touch with him so I'm
going to start doing I don't want to
start doing loads and loads of
interviews it's not what I do but yeah
um
I would love to talk to you and why not
and yeah so real quick while we're on
the Stargate topic
um he oh yeah no he was in oh it was bad
um
and he's a bit mental really
um follow him on Twitter he's not quite
right
um I'm not quite sure
I was brilliant character
um and he got don't get wrong he seems
nice enough
um
it's just it's just a minute weird
I think he's a
I think it's just I think me I'm hoping
he's just like act too weird you know
what I mean he's just like yeah a
creative person but sometimes you put
stuff on just like
I don't know that's I don't think he's
being funny
so um
what happened to him do you know what
what the tragic accident was sort of car
accident or something I'm trying to
remember I've talked to me because it
was a while ago now but he was in quite
a bad accident but more importantly he's
I'd say he's he's just a bit of a funny
character follow him on Twitter you'll
see what I mean quite quickly okay okay
can you still like
[Music]
I actually did think about approaching
him and trying to get him on the show
but then after I follow him on Twitter
for a little while
so um it'd still be cool maybe because
he's somebody that could easily come
back and
Stargate and and be great I I I feel bad
for that character and he's just
whenever he laughs screwed over oh he
didn't get screwed over yeah
possible uh oh it was a boast accident
that was right yeah
um
um but I yeah he was um
like I said I'm just saying he keeps
getting into arguments with people on
Twitter as well
uh
so he's um I just I just I don't think
he's quite
I just think he's a bit he's possibly a
bit of a funny character
interesting well he seems like right
I think that's him
hey well I I like eccentric folk you
know I could be a bit eccentric every
now and then you know who else is a
little eccentric
let's see
[Laughter]
we were waiting for the perfect time oh
he is eccentric boy get in
our our favorite are you talking about
corinamic by any chance yes no we're
talking about Sylvester Stallone again
he's also a little bit eccentric just a
tad no no current yeah Curry name it is
very weird
oh very weird sorry my monitor is making
doing some weird flashing but I don't
know what's wrong with that it's okay
man goes in and out every time I move
and I move way too often so yeah
uh yeah but weird goes good with sci-fi
it goes well with sci-fi right
oh his Twitter account is is very very I
like him I like him I really do but he
is but I don't know it's like it's like
he's not he doesn't even realize he's
famous and like he's just tweeting what
you think whatever
well but it's random and he wanders off
on things but he uh honestly people will
jump on him he just starts massive
arguments with him as well he continues
the argument
and it's sort of like you you you are
actually famous I mean why are you
arguing with this person yeah
it's like just just let it be there's a
great Paul McCartney song for that that
the Beatles saying it just let it be let
it be that that was me when I was argue
with him Joseph malozi obviously you're
supposed to say I keep saying malozi but
apparently
um I've always said milosie
I hope y'all make up one day well it's
not it's very unlikely so we've blocked
each other
well it was horrible and to be honest he
was a prick so I was possibly a little
bit of a prick first but then he
definitely was always member you can't
see you can't say Joseph malozi's or my
love he's a prick honestly I was trying
to where we talk about Stargate he was
to me
I told you the story
so do you mind if I completely steal
your show for five minutes out you you
basically said that you disagreed on
climate change and then you didn't like
elaborate so I don't know the story yeah
I remember the Twitter thread I just
remember chuckling that's that's awesome
that's a story
um on his Twitter feed about how the the
EU were withholding funding to North and
African nations to build a um Factory
that was going to produce
um stuff to put on
Farms what's it called
um like nitrates and stuff to put on
farms because it didn't meet their
environmental standards right
pesticides and things yeah if you
actually read the story though they
weren't refusing to give them the money
they were saying that you can only get
the grant if you meet these
environmental standards and they weren't
so they weren't getting the money
so I said no if you read the story it's
not oh and Joseph malozi's argument was
well that's going to cause jobs and it's
going to kill people it's going to cost
lives
so that started the discussion I said
well it's got to meet their
environmental standards I answered the
argument as well if it's their money if
they say you've got to meet these
standards it was fertilizero
um if you're going to meet these
standards then you've got to meet their
standards so it's their money they can
do what they want with it yeah but it's
not fair anyway because the environment
is so important that started the
conversation now Joseph malozi sort of
stepped out of this a little bit and got
this let this other guy get into it but
Joseph Mosey kept dropping in every so
often but at one point I called this guy
that was arguably an idiot because he
actually said that we'll never run out
of petroleum we'll never run out we are
running out we I know we are but we're
talking about because Peak stuff keeps
dying so we keep adding to it so I'm
like yeah but it took a million it took
tens of millions of years did they not
know how fertilization works
be adding to it but not enough to keep
up with demand it's just so no so I said
but that argument went on for like two
days have you got a spare two million
years just yeah exactly
some bit take all over my keyboard
this guy so I actually went look if you
actually believe this you're an idiot
and Joseph jumped on me anyway you you
how you retract into name calling about
and I said no no fair enough I shouldn't
have done that
um he's a [__] but I shouldn't have
called him a [__]
um I should have called him
but I said no no fair enough
um I I let my temper get away from me
um so then this guy started telling me
that glaciers aren't in retreat
right all around the world and I said
all except one are in Retreat around the
world which we should be worried about I
I've seen one I went to New York I went
to um Norway and I walked up this Valley
and it there's Marcus where it was in
like 1920 1930 1940 and you have to walk
like 10 minutes between each of these
markers and then after about an hour
walking up this Valley you finally got
to the glacier and I was like [__] the
last hundred years it's retreated about
two miles and this is a little glacy
this isn't a big one but um so I was
just like no no they're all in Retreat
then Joseph malozi shared a story about
how the Great Barrier Reef is fine
because I said about ocean acidification
and how that's a problem
no they're not they're fine and again
I'm like if you read the story it says
that the Great Barrier Reef is being
protected in some places and actually
planting coral and that's doing well but
it only actually makes up 25 of the
Great Barrier Reef the rest and 75 is
dying so I mean what are you on about
read the story
there but the thing that he then with he
then blocked me was I argued look if I'm
wrong
it's going to cost a few jobs a bit of
money it might cost a few lives in North
Africa and places like that because
we're going to do environmental stuff
but if you're wrong
the worst thing to happen is the planet
will die
um at best billions of people die tens
of million people you know so I mean I
think side on the air of caution and do
all these things that we've got to do
anyway because pollution is bad oil is
going to run out and you know
Technologies moving beyond petrol anyway
so we're going to do these things anyway
go on yeah
um well it was at that point you blocked
me I mean now I blocked him and then
somebody told me about half an hour
later he's blocked you as well but I
blocked him first because then well I
said this oh sorry his mate then started
calling me a bunch of names I'm kind of
calling me all sorts so I went Joe how
come you ain't jumping in now I called
him an idiot and you're all over me
where are you now he's he's calling me
everything under the sun where are you
um any some nonsense inside so I [__]
blocked him and then um I about a month
later sorry I thought oh maybe I
shouldn't have blocked him so I went
back and thought maybe I should think
and he blocked me anyway so so we
blocked each other so um but Brad Ryan
yeah well Brad Reich actually
um I said something about this on
Twitter and one of them the guys and I
sort of said I don't like Joseph I don't
get on with Joseph because of his
politics and Brad went what politics so
I just said well it's a climate change
denier and Brad Wright didn't comment
so he didn't defend him it just went I
can almost imagine they're going I don't
know
with his denying of the climate thing
um you can also get in trouble by
commenting either way though yeah yeah
he had to leave a million miles but if
he wanted to he could have defended him
couldn't he he didn't so
um to be fair if Brad had went either
way with that
like you're telling the story now like
that would be news and he doesn't want
that yeah
um and I say Brad Wright being prickly
and defending SGU of course he should be
it's personal to him yeah
he should defend it that's his that's
his baby
so and I would and you know if somebody
says to me so much [__] about Sidetrack
I'll get a bit offensive
um unless they're looking at an earlier
video which we did like two years ago in
this guy said God I couldn't I was
terrible
never watched the old videos
um but you know you do
you put a lot of hard work into this the
dude on Reddit who called us idiots from
the north but that's always going to be
in my head you know because I'm not from
the north
do not call me Northern it's in London
though mate everything north of Watford
is normal so
um
is it bad that all I might just me I
read that as all we need is weed and
then I I didn't actually like read the
actual sentence
I can have so much trouble and they did
a video about zpms did you say zpm are
you Canadian only Shelly and Carrie can
say that
I say zpm oh did I say Deadpool I'm not
sure man that's pretty fair We're
British and British is XYZ it's not XYZ
yeah I think I said zpm I say zpm
because that's how they say it in the
show but
yeah
if we were being British about it it's
Zed
you did Rich
Joseph
he trust me if he wanted to be a writer
on this grips I did who did that
and Ritz sends me the description
sometimes and I have tried to sort of
pass them on to people but nobody wants
to accept scripts I have actually read
what you sent me and they are pretty
good hey that's what's good it's just
it's it's hard to set time to read an
entire script down because uh
or set time to read entire script for
somebody because you want to like give
notes and stuff and it takes a long time
to actually like
one guy that works as an agent and he I
sort of said I would try to get them to
send them to him and he said they
basically accept them once a year but
when it came to it it's I can't remember
if um something had happened but he said
now
[Music]
well
wait wait I did see it earlier I wanted
to bring it up mission impossible James
Bond versus Jason Bourne versus John
Wicked he wasn't right
that was hilarious though there's enough
[__] coming out of them to sustain us
for forever
all politicians to be fair that is true
I miss I didn't read them but no he
wasn't right he was completely wrong but
actually no there is enough
you can just [__] all the methane out
the top of them Brussels and power and
nuclear reactor we won't get into it at
all but uh yesterday was all
Independence Day on this side of the
pond and uh that's like it's this proof
in the pudding quite literally that
there's enough [__] to keep us all uh
sustained for a long time coming out of
all these politicians treating is the
reason for the season but anyway uh over
here that's we lost a crapload of tax
income day
but no I remember we were all that tax
income that we lost ah
stupid Americans with this stupid
Freedom wow we gave it to everybody else
as well
we kind of pushed you to do it just a
tad I guess but after World War II you
insisted yeah
I mean like we don't want to give into
your back given to you back
oh y'all haven't seen across the
spider-verse yet have either one of you
seen it yet
I've not seen it yet but it's the second
one
it's not technically a spoiler uh uh so
so mute for about 20 seconds if you
don't want to hear anything at all about
across the spider verse but it's not bad
there's just a very funny line they go
to okay okay okay
we'll we'll skip it
29 about colonialism from the Indian
Spider-Man and it's great it's great
okay I'll look forward to it
um
uh yeah but
all around just just give us some more
Stargate at this point bring everybody
back just let everybody have well you
can bring everybody back that's that's
the perfect world you were talking about
movies earlier you were talking about um
when I was here you were talking about
uh Tom Cruise
um and Mission Impossible needing to
make like was it 1.2 billion or
something well well 828 million dollar
budget between the both of them which is
shy because the Avengers Infinity war
and endgame had a 1.1 billion dollar
budget so that's just insane that two
Mission Impossibles are almost that high
uh but they expect the projected revenue
for it as of now is 3.5 billion between
both of those films
right well you were saying saying that
it needs to make this much money blah
blah in the current climate
that doesn't give me very much hope for
Stargate movie
I was thinking about that when you when
you said it when you said it and how how
much like uh What's this called Indiana
Jones
I had to look at my box set to remember
what it was called
Destiny there don't worry
like that made what I what did you say
800 or was it less than that
it the the the one that's out right now
yeah it made one one uh 82 uh uh or 85.
it was projected to make 82 and made 85
and it opening I guess weekend across
the globe it was 130. okay so well for
what we've heard about potential budgets
with movies if they're going to be doing
100 million and things like even Indiana
Jones isn't making that much money
is it is it is it looking is it looking
good but then in the same vein
um Top Gun did quite well because it was
nostalgic so would Stargate be in the
same vein
have a budget I mean um Indiana Jones's
budget was two to three hundred million
dollars the Stargate budget is not good
auction budget is going to be 60 70.
yeah so I was gonna say up to 100
million
so they could make that if if it's
reasonably successful they'd make that
back
and remembering that's not the worldwide
either the world that was the US take
wasn't it obliviated 85. I think that
should be basically done about the same
again worldwide so it has made about two
talk about 200 million dollars the
problem with Indiana Jones is though
it's the production
um budget was estimated to be two to
three hundred million dollars but you
can add another 50 60 million dollars I
think it's lowballed at 300 right
because they had to do another year of
rewrites for men gold to come on SO in
that case you're looking at closer to
400 million oh absolutely well for
marketing budget you typically want to
double it and Disney spent
not normally normally it's about 20 to
30 percent normally no most people talk
about 40 million dollars to to
promote
nowadays I feel like it's a lot higher
uh it it tends to be higher like
I I think I'm going off MCU numbers I
typically spend nearly double the budget
or 50 of what they spent the first time
around for it so if that's the case you
have to they have to make at least
500 450 500 million dollars at at most
600 million dollars uh to really get
any type of cash flow any type of
Revenue
which is not what Disney and lucasfim
want but I think part of that is Disney
and lucasfilm that's uh the hesitation
there
yeah tell us in the comments we like
this we always wander back to the
subject to eventually Kev come on but of
course okay keep us on track sometimes
go and subscribe to Harris's Channel
because when we get on and we we we come
and do this
we do have some really good chats yes we
will event like wander off and like talk
about absolute crap
for about three hours but we will
eventually get back to the topic at hand
and you have to listen to a lot of
waffling and nonsense but then when it's
good oh it's gold oh it's great
sometimes you get nuggets of like just
really good conversation like we we
spoke for about an hour about AI
nothing to do with the video absolutely
nothing to do with the video but it was
a great conversation great conversation
that that was one of my favorite streams
we've done oh it was a lot of fun
stormy and I may have done that a little
bit yesterday as well
we started off
Sidetrack is a little bit more focused
we talk about sci-fi we talk about
things we wander off here and there
thanks to stormy occasionally but we do
try to I try to keep it focused because
we're trying to do one hour videos here
and this is why you should come over to
M3 and you should M cubed whatever you
want to call M cubed in it hello we're
live on M cubed at the same time
we're doubling up I didn't realize I I
saw I saw the video in my feed and I was
like Harwich you're on the wrong Channel
yeah no no no I'm with we're streaming
to try and get some love over to Harris
but because we're gonna do more where we
are a bit Freer we can talk about
whatever the hell we like
yourself
we started casting a little bit earlier
and we were like well hold up we might
have to hold that back just a tad
Matthew I said [__] twice now
[Laughter]
oh well never mind
um what else we're supposed to talk
about Harris you got other stuff on your
list
for for getting back to topic we have
technically three three four topics the
the one is kind of uh roped together and
let's start with that one because it's
fairly simple and we can kind of uh by
the way I'm going at night I I need to
leave at nine as well okay
14 minutes ago
all right well I wouldn't say I've got a
life I just gotta go watch a Walking
Dead
[Music]
um I've actually uh Dave is going to get
angry at me but I've started quite
enjoyed that wolf pack I want to go
watch another episode
I was watching the expanse earlier on
the way to work
I'm getting back into that because I
it's been about three or four months
yeah since we last watched last trip
yeah I get you
I've completely forgot about the ring
portal thing the Ring The Ring space
I completely forgot about it and I was
halfway through an episode when I left
it off like three months ago so I
started halfway through an episode where
the Martian like guys talk about Ring
space I'm like oh yeah yeah that's the
thing it's like Stargate but not foreign
let me uh let me pull her up real quick
um
wait wait wait
we've already been talking for an hour
and a half and I can generally remember
anything we've talked about did we talk
did we talk about Mission Impossible we
did yeah yeah no we we spent an hour
uh-huh so we we got a little we can make
this into a longer topic if we want to
but we can do it quickly as well
sutterberg is a wonderful director and
he's he's kind of on AI side he's not
opposed to it there's a giant M M's ad
um
now we're back okay I'll read this real
quick then y'all just give me your
thoughts on this okay I've used it for
stuff to play around with but I've never
gotten into like a q a with it I'd be
curious to be interacting with it and go
hey can we take a five minute break
leave come back and then ask it what
were you thinking about while I was gone
to see if it had an answer at all and if
it did what if what its answers was what
is five minutes what is four hours to an
AI I don't know so I think it's a useful
tool for design creation I think it's
interesting for a basic way to
accumulate a framework if somebody goes
I want to do NCIS in Barcelona you load
in every episode of that shows that
that's been made anywhere in the world
and you load in all the Barcelona
information you can come up with and
this thing spits out a very frumainty
version of how you would do NCIS in
Barcelona then that that then actual
human beings will have to figure out how
to make interesting
mm-hmm
I completely agree with that way of
thinking about with AI
it is just a tool and it's no I don't
think it's ever going to replace
writers not overall yes there are
certain industries that are leaning more
towards it but
the onus is then on the the writer to
look through what's generated make sure
it makes sense so they're in a way to
become more of an editor yeah
um to make sure it makes sense but also
they can then inject their own creative
ideas into it and adapt it to their
creative ideas because the problem with
AI
is it's only going to regurgitate what
it already knows it's never going to
create anything new really yeah like
it's not it's not it's not going to
create like the next revolutionary TV
show because it's going to look at the
past the past works of
I don't know let's say we're trying to
create create a new Sci-Fi show it's
going to look at all of Star Trek all
the Star Wars maybe not Star Wars
um all of the
expansion sci-fi good Sci-Fi Star Trek
it's going to look at everything it's
going to then come up with an idea
um but that idea is going to be based on
everything that's come before it there's
not going to be any forward thinking
it's all yeah this has happened so let's
adapt let's create something around that
yes it will be a new idea in a way
but it's not it's the same idea spun
differently
and that's the point I'm trying to make
um AI is never going to create anything
new it's always going to be up to
creatives to do it and I think
AI doing these jobs is actually going to
give people more creative freedom
because they've got more time to create
rather than edit and and write scripts
and all stuff like that and stuff like
this they've got more time to think
about the worlds they're building and
they can feed that into an AI to be like
come up with a story for me this the eye
will be like yep cool this is what I
think you could do and then they can
like edit it make it their own kind of
thing but I think overall it would
because it's a tool it's a tool to Aid
creativity
so I completely agree with everything
that that guy said yeah no I I'm in
complete agreeance as well Jamie looks
like you may not be over there well what
do you think the problem I have and the
thing I would concern me is that
um for one you're a tool and you're
talking everyone's cool I just want to
say it all the way through I understand
everything but
um
it it won't be used like that it'll be
used and it will it will be put people
out of jobs
and we will see less writers because the
thing is
as well a lot of TV is quite formulaic
so you're saying about it won't create
something original a lot of producers
like on think they don't want something
original they want something people will
watch and the thing is if you program
the AI right it'll spit out stuff that
is Formula it can be watching it might
not be creative it might not be
different but there'll be still be
people that love it or hate it
if it's successful and if they are
allowed to basically replace writers
with AI My worry is that it'll happen
a lot
and that okay you might then bring in a
writer to
polish it but it's still going to be
um generated by an AI because it's much
much cheaper and quicker
an AI can if it's programmed rifle spit
out really 10 scripts a minute
[Music]
foreign
Darth Vader impression but I do think
there's a massive risk if we open the
door to AI that it won't be just used as
a different sort of tool it will be used
and it doesn't just stop at writing
because AI is already starting to
generate imagery it starts to be used to
that to be honest
where was Ai and this isn't we could
call this AI it's not really AI not
really but it's nearly as it's we're
getting really close it's not an
intelligence it's just machine learning
what Soderberg said in that little
article real quick whenever whenever
that AI is able to you come back in five
minutes and then it answers the question
of
what are you even talking about what are
you even thinking about and then it has
an actual answer that's artificial
intelligence yeah
but we're into anything it's able to
fabricate intelligence and to a point
where it's almost on the level so and
and but 10 years ago we were nowhere
with this where the hell are we going to
be in another 10 years
it will be generating scripts I think
and and Hollywood will use it because
it'll be much much cheaper so I
understand why the writers strike is
making such a big deal out of AI now
because they're saying look all right
this isn't a problem now but five years
ago this wasn't even a consideration
where the hell are we going to be in 10
years
and we're gonna we open the door to it
it's not going to be a tool it's going
to be a battering ram and that's what
worries me
I do agree
with some of what you've just said yeah
however
with AI generated content we've already
seen it happen so we've got AI generated
art
it hasn't replaced artists
artists are still creating because
people know when something is generated
by Ai and they separate the two and and
I'd argue that artists have actually
started popping out of the Woodworks
more now because they feel pressurized
they feel that pressure
yep
also
if I I completely agree that it's going
to be used for everything you've just
said yeah people will use it to write
scripts people will use it to write
entire movies to write and type books
but
those will slowly die out the same way
when air first came up everyone was
using it on everyone's profile picture
everyone was using it for their
thumbnails everyone was using it for
absolutely everything but it slowly died
out
it's it's still used by a few people
of quite a few people actually still
very very popular I'm not gonna just
water it down it's very popular
it was a gimmick at first it wasn't it
everybody was doing it like two years
ago in the last 18 months or so it's
like
yeah well it hasn't replaced graphic
graphic artists it hasn't replaced
actual artists I mean if if you if you
were going to make the argument of
graphic artists you could all you could
always say there's always ordering tools
that can replace you anyway things like
canva can do it pretty quickly that's
not even AI That's just a talk that's
just a regular tool
I think it will happen so they will
start making these scripts for TV shows
and movies Etc but
because it's formulaic because it's only
going to be drawing on things from the
past it's going to dry out really
quickly and it's not going to be
anything fresh in order to look at just
audiences are just going to get bored
people are going to re they're going to
see what's happening because every movie
is going to come out with exactly the
same sort of formula yeah based on a
trend so they'll see what's what's
popular right that's what happens now
no but if a computer generates something
based on trends
audiences are going to realize oh this
this was made written by an AI because
of this thing that happened three weeks
ago
there's no creativity and people now
it's just a human like movies do you
think it's a yes
the difference is now humans humans have
to create there are waves and troughs
therefore sci-fi is popular for a bit
then rom-coms come popular so as soon as
you get one hit then all the other
Studios try to replicate it and that'll
still happen but it'll happen a lot
quicker
I would argue it's not a bad thing
necessarily because what have we been
kind of talking about the last couple
days with with the death of not
necessarily the death of the box office
or anything like that but just the lack
of a lot of these films making money and
and what could be the issue of what
actually like franchise fatigue it could
realistically be is probably the
producers and things like that and it's
not just the producers it's the writers
not being as creative because it's death
by committee AI I think is the same
thing as it's doing the exact same thing
as the Committees are doing I don't
think it's very different in that aspect
and I know Richard fortin's been been
agreeing with you a hundred percent over
here but he did because I'm right well
right he he just also completely
disassembled all y'all's art that's not
necessarily disassembled but like
creativity is a human trait there's no
way that AI is going to be able to do
something it like like all this like the
Committees are doing as well they're not
coming up with new things they might try
to fit a new tidbit into something but
they're not trying to come up with new
things I think Ai and death by committee
are the exact same thing and that's what
Riders should be focused about in this
Rider strike is their own
validity and and what their
mindset and their like prerogative is
not necessarily like okay can we keep
getting a paycheck and get sit on this
and and sit on a set and do this yes
that's great and it's necessary that
they should be actual employees and not
like necessarily uh uh freelance for
every single gig especially if it's a
multi-year gig kind of deal
I just don't think AI is any different
than committee right now I I think I
agree with you on that one
it'll be even more committee I agree
that because
at a faster rate though because if it
happens at a faster rate turn out the BS
and then it allows people to have that
time and and the people that want to use
AI as a tool can and the one because I
feel like the Committees are the same
people that are scared of AI that those
are the nearly the same people a lot of
times because they're they they want
that control of something and it's about
control versus creativity the problem
again the problem again with an AI like
you mentioned that like AI in graphics
wasn't putting artists out of business
I'd argue try and be an artist to make
money
it would be my one thing it's you could
make a career in art hasn't always been
a case though well like you could as a
graphic artist or as a as an artist on a
TV show you could make money 20 years
ago I don't think there are many they're
making money nowadays you have to be a
programmer nowadays it's more about
coding
and being able to use the things and
being an artist because the the computer
does most of the work so that'd be my
one point my other point is though the
problem is the AI
can do the thingy by committee but you
can cut the writer out completely
so you can tell and the AI now don't
forget what's it going to be like in
another five years you're going to be
able to tell the AI do me a script in
the style of an Arnold Schwarzenegger
movie written by this fella and I want
it to be this blah blah blah and a
committee will be able to tell you and
they'll spit it'll be instant it'll not
raise a script and they'll read the
script they'll do it in an afternoon
they'll read the script no no actually
would like a little bit more humor boom
done straight out again right okay let's
read that yeah we like that and we don't
really like that because we want to be a
little bit more titularly human a bit
more humor in the style of this guy and
it'll just be bomb straight immediately
next one again straight away
you completely you could completely move
and the why the reason why they'll do it
and not all of them you'll still get
writers and you'll still get them every
single project but it'll be a lot of
projects and the reason why they'll do
it is because it's cheaper
and that's why they'll do it it's
cheaper and it'll be it'll be cheaper
mainly because it'll be loads quicker
there's no day of meeting with the
writer going we'd really like you to do
this we'd really like to do that can you
go into this and then come back in a
month and go okay we'll see what you've
done with that we like that but can you
do this it won't be it'll be fun
is that a bad thing it's a business and
you want to make money in a business and
no matter what you you need to continue
making money to continue making more
movies and only in the fact is they
don't do it too much
but but what is too much though you know
like the same thing nowadays MCU
committee like it I I it's kind of
semantics in that matter of thinking I
guess
but just yeah no actors that's that's
where I think AI would be scary down the
road with with with that thought process
I I just think even if it is fewer
writers because that
that very well might be the case and I
think that probably will happen with AI
is it it's kind of does a lot of that
grunt that leg work for you and and but
there's always got to be that human
touch
and and
as long as that's their
to follow that might even allow one
person to come up with a lot more that
that AI might bring us the next George
Lucas where these committees would be
killing the next George Lucas they would
never let something like that happen
nowadays and now ai has put that tool
for any of us to become George Lucas in
our pockets
what you've just said
this has already happened in the past
so back in
I don't know when it was the 60s 70s
there would be there would be rows and
rows of women
and they were called computers because
what they would do is they would do
calculations for businesses okay and
then what came about in the 80s
actual what we now call computers you
took their jobs
but we still have accountants and that's
essentially what they were doing
we still have accountants and they make
a [__] time more money than what
computers ever did yeah my wife is an
accountant she does very very well thank
you very much but their role has changed
the computer does most the work
the role of an accountant is more like a
manager nowadays
uh control so so so following on from
what Harry said was is that not the same
the the point is I think you are a
completely you there is a potential here
to completely eliminate
the writer would become an editor
instead of a writer is what we're saying
so what he's saying is is it a bad thing
that the AI would create something and
then the writer would come along and go
well I can just polish this up what what
okay
the AI wouldn't be creating something
first you have to prompt it so that
writer is still coming up with all of
the bases for the ideas he's that he or
she whoever the writer is is coming up
with
everything besides
little tidbits and he can take those
tidbits if he wants and and then go and
either minimize them maximize them for
whatever part of the story they're in
but
when you edit a video
if you're on your phone or you're on a
computer you're moving a mouse using the
keyboard you're putting inputs in you're
telling the computer what you want yours
technically if we're going to be using
the same logic
you're not editing your own videos all
you're doing is giving an input
to the machine who is doing it for you
that's essentially what AI does but
essentially a little bit better because
it can learn from its from the past
when if I was editing a video with AI
I'm not punching anything in oh well I
would I would at the start I would say
right here's my unedited version I'd
like you to create a video please and
I'd like you to do it with these
parameters go
um my input is the really only as far as
that I can then maybe polish it when
we're done when I edit a video I'm going
in and I'm actually cutting slices and
putting it and removing bits and I and I
can figure out the the the the you know
the pace of the video and what have you
and and I can be creative as I'm going
along
well okay so tell me what to do next
does it it doesn't
what would that with that thought
process I I guess you could arguably
just type in like hey edit this for me
and and do it in in my style or
something like that and or you could
just say hey edit this for me and it
might just do like the most simplistic
editing like but you would still have to
tell it what to edit out it wouldn't
just be like hey edit for me unless you
plugged in your first 300 videos and
then it was like edit this in the style
of Sidetrack yeah but you know what
about doing that now I'm on about What's
it gonna be like in 10 days I'm not on
about using AI today I'm on about if we
open the door to this what they are
going to be doing in 10 years well like
you said with accounting it's it's
different the whole landscape of it is
different than what it was it's
intrinsically the same thing but the
landscape and the way we think about it
the way we interact with it and the way
the employees deal with like customers
and stuff like that is different
yeah that's going to happen no matter
what AI is just kind of the next step in
progressivism or human evolution
transhumanism whatever you want to call
it at the end of the day uh I I I I I I
get the argument that was basically
saying look this is a new technology and
we'll evolve and we'll adapt to it right
I understand that but I don't think this
is quite the same as when we put
machines into car manufacturing
and we you know and we remove that you
know it's a tough horrible job and we
created robots you can do it loads
better and loads of people and but we
evolved I don't think it's quite the
same as that people lost their jobs
loads of people lost their jobs but the
you know our employment industry our
economy changed
um we moved a lot of our jobs in the
west we do loads of jobs that we don't
want to do in the west so we let other
countries do it that are poorer and
they'll do it for less money and now we
don't really want to so train this
together so we'll let Thailand do it and
whatever so I mean that's how our
economy works unfortunately
what we're talking about here though is
actually starting to remove some of
those High
skilled jobs so being a writer being a
novelist is not something anybody can do
it's a high skill role
and we're actually even removing that
I'm just saying that there's got to be a
line and if we are we though the problem
is if we if the first AI written movie
makes a billion dollars everybody's
going to want to do it
to cancel that argument
so we're talking with we mentioned video
ai's editing videos
AI candidate videos now they're pretty
good at it you can say to them it's cut
out all the arms and Ours
do a few lens flares I don't know
whatever
but there are still insanely good
editors who can do a way better job and
they get paid handsomely for it so I
think the same is going to be true for
writers the AI can probably do a pretty
good job
but there's going to be people creative
people talented creative people who can
do it way better and that's always going
to be the case because because humans
can do things that machines cannot we
can create things that never existed
before we don't have to draw we don't
have to look at everybody of work in the
past and then make something based on
that we can imagine we can have new
ideas whereas a computer can never do
that so it's fun as long as if we lose
90 percent of writers in Hollywood right
now that's fine though because the top
will always be able to keep their jobs
and be always be able to well
I think
if that brought
because
at all these people might end up
incorporating uh into their job for all
the reasons that we mentioned before
like just to come up with a rough idea
or they've got rough idea on the head
they pull it in and then it comes up
with like an outline or something like
that and then that could fuel their
imagination
and they'll be like oh actually I didn't
think of that before
and then that Spurs on more creativity
and it's just a tool for enhancing
creativity that's it I would actually
argue that I think I agree with you
in in the respect of using so I think
the writers strike what they need to do
is they need to basically say that AI
cannot be hired as a person
right so you can't hire an AI to write a
script what you can do is a writer can
use AI
to help him create a script quicker or
whatever but then a writer's thing but
then that's that's the point of a lot of
the strike that's going on at the moment
though is that the studios don't want to
accept that
for me that's a simple thing you cannot
use AI as a person don't know the same
way you wouldn't hire a computer as a
person a computer at all you wouldn't
hire AI as a person because it's at all
that's why AI is dangerous though
because it can replace a person
pretty much completely
um and you know all you then need is
exactly
the barriers and you can have a program
and they're going yeah do you want it to
be in this style do you want to be in
that style and again maybe not now but
in 10 years what you're talking about is
custom language models they are
expensive it's very expensive no no all
the time
technology is going to be how much
better in 10 years
it's not the technology it's the amount
of information that you have to feed it
for it to get better and you have to
train it
yeah but but that's my point though
isn't it but as you start building
things like this that are trained and
there are like say this this technology
it will become cheaper because it will
become
it'll be established
it will
be trained to a point
and then it can't be trained on anything
more because if we then start using it
to do everything
the only other things it's got to draw
on is things it's already created and
it's going to be just a loop of creating
the same things over and over and over
again
it can do a billion of those Cycles a
minute
yeah but we've only got so much
information to feed it if we don't if
people then use it all the time
it can spit out a hundred thousand
scripts one of the things with AI is the
why it's so terrifying is because it can
it's going to be so amazing for creating
new technologies and new designs because
one thing to do is they all set up and
they'll say well we want you to build
the perfect mouse trap and it will just
go and just just design a billion mouse
traps in a few seconds and
999.9999 of them are a nonsense crap
but the last one it's like a million
monkeys tapping away a million
typewriters and then eventually they'll
make they'll create they'll spit out
Shakespeare but randomly that's what an
AI can do but it takes seconds
it doesn't take exactly it takes a lot
longer
but we're talking we're not talking
about today we're talking about 10 years
that's the point we're talking about
opening a technology quantum computers
quite a while but we're talking about
technology it didn't exist 10 years ago
but even like no Jennifer generative
um algorithms have existed for decades
this is all it is
generative in the way they're being used
today right so AI or what we what
they're calling AI today
in the principles it was used didn't
exist 10 years ago did it it wasn't
being used like it is they though those
programs were nothing like a
sophisticated
we like in another 10 years particularly
remembering we're now getting AI
creating next-gen AI programs they're
writing their own programs and I'm not
talking about Terminator this is going
to be terminated it doesn't go anything
of that nonsense it whatever it could be
it's but what we're talking about is
that this is an exponential increase in
technology
but
yeah it's going to be there is going to
be a limit
no because
well eventually AI will quite positively
limit itself it will yes
as I said
so how how much of human history is it
gonna is it realistic gonna be able to
draw on
everything that's on the internet so
let's let's say we've got records going
back
I don't know what we've got text
textbooks going back up to 1800s 1700s
maybe yeah
that's what 400 years yeah human history
is it can it can go through that
information very quickly I mean the
whole of Wikipedia can fit on like three
hard drives three three pretty big hard
drives
all right it's not a lot of information
in the grand scheme of things no
eventually
it's going to go for all that
information it's going to generate all
the possible like variations of
permutations of of that information and
make these new stories which isn't
actually new it's just variations of
what we have before to the point where
it's going to then
it's then going to have to just start
drawing on stuff it's already created
and it's going to be alone all humans do
we don't know we haven't created
anything new for a thousand years
what do you mean we haven't created
anything new we have a great what do
they recognize okay it's basic stories a
light bulb the light bulb right spacious
new technology and we're talking about
AI right I'm talking about ideas
there are six basic stories there are
currently and that how many times have
we Rewritten Shakespeare you know or
just reimagine Shakespeare stories music
music is exactly the same they reckon
we're actually getting to a Tipping
Point when it comes to music where there
won't be any new music anymore it's just
going to be variations of what's already
happened because there's only so many
combinations to notes there's only so
many combinations there's billions don't
get me wrong
so there is only certain combinations
with with the notes we play but maybe
we'll do something creative and create
something that doesn't yet exist that is
what humans do we are the only people
the only thing on this planet that
create things that have never existed
before yeah oh yeah no like 100 agree
with you but when it works as well doing
stories we haven't created a a properly
original story
in thousands of years they're all
nations of stores that have been told
before all of them uh Frank Hebert's
Doom
sorry Frank Ebert's dune or was it Brian
Hebert whatever whatever daddy Hebert
was for Dune you break my arm it's
variations of of stories that have been
told before there's nothing there's
nothing truly original sometimes you'll
get somebody that does something a
little bit of a Twist or something think
but are you breaking anything any Story
down to basic I mean basically June is
about
um
and revenge and um double crossing and
it's a political thriller it's a story
that's been told a billion times they
will always be told
um Harry Potter was one of the biggest
franchises we've seen in the last 20
years it's basically a ripoff of the
worst witch that was a kid's show when I
was a kid it's exactly the same story
except Voldemort's in Italy or nothing
but Voldemort is Ivan something from uh
it's like a very common Russian folk
tale as well no exactly so these things
are that it's the same stories told them
and an AI will just do the same thing
the humans do but it'll do it quicker
okay I I understand what you're saying I
don't agree but I do
I mostly agree I feel like I agree 80
because humans like like uh what mohal
said earlier Mojo said earlier art
engineering are built on what came
before no matter what we are inclined to
kind of like think and and because
that's what we know like like now look
at all the movies we get they're half
nostalgic most things are just Nostalgia
kind of uh
your brain likes that and that's what we
go towards but we have the capacity and
capability to create new things
nonetheless and we we do that and and
whether it be derived from something old
or not it doesn't
take away from the fact that it is a new
idea or a new piece of art or a new
piece of engineering everything has to
be derived from something it doesn't
make it not new and I guess the the
thing that I would uh uh hear Matt
you'll yeah there you are uh the the
thing that I would say differentiates us
and Ai and robots Terminator c3pos
whatever the hell it ends up being
everything in this the ninth law of
physics is math essentially that's the
easiest way just to say it it's it's the
building blocks of the universe
everything is derived from math
our brains have the capacity for
creativity
everything we think of is gonna be able
to be like defined through mathematics
at a certain point but we don't
necessarily think about it in a
mathematical way to start off the AI has
to do everything through mathematics
they they don't have that creativity
aspect things everything's completely
logic based where we might we might have
like this logical old witch story or
something and then oh let's add uh this
here and then make it Harry Potter
whatever you know it's just the uh it's
quite a creative thing Mass was a
creative
massive infiltrated
the foundation of the um of the Universe
I guess but
someone created it because all it really
is is
um language creative language used to
describe things that you can't
the zero is the most important invention
probably of mankind because actually
zero doesn't exist it's a concept
which was come up by
an invented by or thought up by people
yeah well I thought you meant
specifically then because it came out of
Iraq but um but yeah so um
but but yeah no and I understand that
but that's for me that's probably one of
the most creative things we've ever done
but again it was ten thousand years ago
um it was you know I'm just saying
anything our advancement in technology
now how much actual advancement in
technology has been done by man
in the last 20 years the newest Boeing
was wasn't designed by men it was
designed by
um computers almost all of it
who gave them the information yeah who
originally came up with that information
the parameters but a lot of that
airplane was designed by computers the
actual original designers the the newest
Google quantum computer was designed by
its predecessor
we might have created we might do the
foundation but we are not clever enough
to actually then create the next thing
we need the computers to support us so
I'll bring you the exact opposite where
the computers rely on our cleverness and
creativity where they they might be able
to do a lot of these things
yes okay you can't do that but we
wouldn't be able to do it without the
computers
either so it's it's a Rel it's a
symbiotic relationship it's irrelevant
really because you can you simply can't
do it
um yeah
um I don't think that's true I think for
a lot of people they rely on computers
and they need it to be able to do these
particular jobs but to say we as
Humanity couldn't have done it without
these computers is completely incorrect
because the information was given to the
computer we already have that
information and it's given enough time
we could have done it
and get it would take too much time is
the problem to be practical what the
computer allows us to do but also
remembering we won't tell a computer
what we want the end product to be and
then we tell a computer how to do it and
what it does is now with these new AI
programs it makes mistakes and learns
and we're getting to a point where we
start the ball rolling but the computer
does the work the program does it makes
loads and loads of mistakes it does a
billion bad rap trap mice traps rat
traps and then it comes up it learns how
to create the perfect mouse trap we
don't tell it we just start the ball
rolling and that's how how a lot of very
complicated systems the new jet
laboratory over in France was designed
by a computer
it was not designed by man we just got
the ball rolling and we worked with it
but all the heavy lifting was done by
the the design software
um but anyway to get back to using AI in
film all I'm saying is
the movies TV and everything is generic
it is for malayic a computer can
simulate that very it can do it now if
we open the door
I'm just saying that you're opening a
door to something that is cheaper
quicker and easier and if you want all
of your TV to be completely controlled
by executives
that's the quickest way to do it because
an executive can hire a bunch of
computer programmers and make a movie
but computer programmer is not going to
be as they might be creative in a
different sense but they're not going to
think about story like a writer would I
I I I I
take it
we know make it easier to interact with
the AI so the creative people can do it
easier
last week
right I have to go
I wanted I'm going to set some homework
for our Sunday video all right so here
we go somewhere for one
genuinely to tell me the last movie or
TV series that was genuinely original
you can always go granular with
everything you look at though and go
that's not original because because at
the very base at the very basis every
movie as a human being that's breathing
the argument for last 45 minutes is that
only humans can be creative and only
humans can create something original so
have a think
and that's your homework come back with
something anything that's been created
in the last 50 years that was truly
original
FernGully if we can't find anything
that's not that's not gonna that's not
gonna give weight to your argument
that's just going to basically prove
that Hollywood is lazy
and but that is but that is my argument
Hollywood is lazy yeah why give it
another tool to be even lazy but but
yeah that but I also think this tool can
make it where people are much less lazy
as well it gives an individual that much
more capability it allows George Lucas's
to flourish again we're a current
Hollywood in the past Hollywood of the
past 50 60 years has been
increasingly death by committee it's
it's you got to have 10 12 people 15
people sign off on something where
if everything goes well of course and
and there will be Studios that use AI in
the way you're thinking of but I think
the one thing that you're omitting from
from the thought process is the consumer
we're we know when shit's fake excuse
the French but we know when things are
fake but most of the time
or at least there's there's an inkling
in our brain that's like it makes us go
it makes us feel iffy about something
since the 60s
well yes that's that's that's methodics
that's mathematics again that's just oh
do you actually it just proves the point
that people are
individuals are very intelligent people
are stupid
and I'm including myself in that and
advertising works because a very
fundamental basic things that stimulate
us and interest us movies movies that
are very very generic and very very
formulaic work and we watch them and we
love them
um The Fast and the Furious franchise
could have very easily been created by
an AI
and we wouldn't we wouldn't notice a
difference that's the most creative
human endeavor I think that there's ever
been
and on that note yeah
oh well do you want to watch The Killers
of the flower Moon trailer no or would
that demonstrate
we've got two more points for Friday
that'll be it thank you all for coming
before y'all leave real quick tell
people where to follow y'all well you're
on sidetracked you all know where to
follow him yeah
um the point of The Tonight Show though
is go over to M cubed and join there
because we don't want to see any more
videos of Harris just having two or
three people on we won 20 30 people are
like we have had tonight so let's get
some more people over to and where me
store me last night
um the idiot Matthew here in the middle
who's
I mean I've screamed shut up Matt in my
head for the last 25 minutes I've not
said it once
so um now I love you guys that's
honestly you've honestly dislike mental
Olympics this evening I've loved it best
best best 45 minutes on a live stream
we've done ages it's been great well the
best part about it is it technically is
just semantics we don't know until like
another
five ten years until that actually
happens so
we're debating discussing hoping until
Terminator knocks on our door we don't
really know see I'm alive and Alive
let's have this conversation on Sunday
have a good
all right well that's it from us y'all
subscribe hit notification you know that
I can't even speak English now ai's
taking my brain over hit that
notification Bell subscribe like do all
that good stuff things are in the
description
thank you all
adios tomorrow
I got a mess I actually have to press n
broadcast not leave Studio